Kevin
um a few questions how old are you and
where do you live again yeah sure I am
51 and I live in Vancouver BC just on uh
and if I recall correctly by going
through some of the material and the
links you gave me um you met your wife
she's Ukrainian was it in Eastern Europe
that you guys met or did you meet her
here
yeah actually we met in cave Ukraine in
the capital while I was living and
studying there
okay and how long ago did you meet her
we met in around 2001 uh she was
actually born and raised in Russia but
then she moved to Ukraine at 14 and then
we met in cave in 2001. and you guys
were working together you guys were in
school together or how did you cross
paths going to school together she was
literally a friend of a colleague so it
happened very quickly and how did you
guys end up in
um British Columbia
yeah no it's a good story so uh very
briefly we married uh actually married
really soon in February of 2002
submitted the documents to local
Canadian embassy and then six months
later she got her immigration papers so
we arrived in Canada in uh 2002
September and then we moved to BC uh two
years later so it's been in Vancouver
ever since and I'm going to keep going
through the background story but just to
sort of fast forward to where we are
today Kevin's kids are now all the way
across the country in Prince Edward
Island uh she left took them did a whole
bunch of Nefarious stuff which we're
going to go through and he's kind of
trying to figure out how to get them
back was this a meal ticket for her to
kind of get from Ukraine to Canada
yeah it's hard it's hard to say in
hindsight there definitely were some
Clues if I can think about like defining
moments in terms of our marriage and we
were married for 16 years by the time we
got separated so the only red plays I
can feel like is she got her passport
and we started having children around
the same time when she got her Canadian
passport and the children everything
just kind of seemed to change and so I
often break up that 16 years of marriage
into two eight year blocks the first
eight years were some sense of normalcy
and then the last eight years were just
like complete like Dr Jekyll and Mr Hyde
the last eight years were a completely
different person
to like like the craziness that came
after the first eight years like did you
see anything before you got married or
before you brought her to Canada or any
of those things
you know we met and got married with
inside of seven months and so that in
hindsight would have been a really big I
know I saw your eyebrows going that's
Hey listen you know that's one of the
things I warn about in my book is make
sure you really you know sort of size
her up for a good couple years see what
she's made of right right higher slow
Fire fast right that's one of your
chapters so yeah uh so I didn't take the
time to really uh to hire her slow it
was it was way too quick uh we started
living together almost immediately like
literally by day three we're living
together and so I kind of felt at that
time that I was committed to her I
needed to take care of her and before
you knew we were married how old is she
when you met her marriage she was about
20 years old when we met when we when we
met
so she was 20 you were about what 30 I'm
trying to do the math 36 37 eight there
was eight years difference I was just
about 29 years old oh 29 okay we got
married when I was with uh when I was 30
and she was uh 22 so around that age
right age range there so yeah I married
her pretty young that said even at 22
she felt like well at least in her
country in Ukraine she felt like she was
an old maid in other words most of her
friends had already been married and had
kids and she was feeling all kinds of
pressure and you said you were married
for 16 years how long did you know her
before you guys got married
the seven months oh so seven months and
then 16 years hang on the numbers don't
add up because you said that you met her
in your late 20s you're you're in your
50s now yeah so uh yeah we met when I
was 29 got married when uh when I was
30. we were married for 16 years that's
when I was 46 and for the past we've
been separated now for four and a half
years so we've been fighting this for
the last few years then
uh almost a half a decade and I and
literally fighting as in like like just
got the last judgment in on August 26th
uh less than two months ago so this is
this is real this is happening this is
live okay got it
um why don't you take us through all the
bullet points that you emailed me here's
kind of you know Enlighten the audience
and guys if you have questions you can
drop them in the chat and I'll uh I'll
throw them up on the screen and let
Kevin answer them as it's relevant
sure well you know I when I was thinking
about how to share this with your
community and first of all I appreciate
you you know taking the time to hear and
share my story with your community
um I wanted to focus sort of on the the
two years prior to separation because
you can see this pattern if you will and
then the months leading up to separation
just like wild crazy and I feel like
that will provide a lot of the backstory
rather than hearing about you know how
is the marriage for the first kind of 10
years so
um it's okay so in the two years prior
to separation uh at that point you know
things weren't well in the relationship
she was basically separating herself and
she was asking for divorce on a pretty
regular basis
and so uh two years before we separated
I started going to I kind of joke I say
I go started going to marriage
counseling by myself which is just
another way of saying that I was going
every week and she only attended maybe
three or four sessions sessions so she
was really not interested in
participating or engaging in any sort of
dialogue so and there's not it's not
very productive even when you go
together you know with her not going at
all it's a colossal waste of time I
would imagine you're just working on
yourself then right
well I did at that time absolutely focus
on myself but at the same time I still
thought I could save the marriage
um right or wrongly
uh also during this time keep in mind uh
she was she'd finished her master's
degree here at the University of British
Columbia by this time she'd already
enrolled in the PHD program in education
at UBC so she was Heavy in all this sort
of University campus stuff and it's
around that time that she started
attending these University dance groups
and parties and she was always
passionate about dance uh from her you
know from her years growing up but this
time it was a little bit different so
she started going out on like weekend
events and then those weekend events
started turning into like late evenings
and then clubs downtown and then these
by meeting all these people she started
having one-on-one interactions with
other guys and I know this part isn't in
the materials that I essentially because
it's pretty hard to put that in a court
document but she started meeting kind of
like a series of guys and what you we
would commonly call White Knights so for
example she met one guy named ed and
this was like this guy started sort of
counseling her on the Canadian legal
system and then she met other guy named
Colin Ford like this total burnt out
rocker for downtown that was another
white knight also counseling her on the
Canadian legal system and then she
started hanging out with another boy
going on like these day trips she was
going out for dinners and then I even
found out later that she started going
up on dates with this guy with my kids
so I have two young kids at that time
and they were going to playgrounds I
even saw pictures later on of them at
the pool together so she is just imagine
taking my kids out with some other guy
on these quasi dates
so yeah why did you let her do all this
like why did you permit her to to go out
and party and and dance all night
I objected but she um basically told me
that it isn't cheating as long as I know
about it
and I said it was wrong I know I know
specifically told me it's not cheating
if you know about it and I said it's
this is wrong there's no point in being
married if she's gonna go out and date
other men you guys have the kids at that
point yeah we should be doing this
before the kids came along
no only after the children came along
okay and by that time her mother was
living with us so I had my mother oh oh
here we go the Babushka showed up
already eh yeah Babushka totally and and
straight to the point like all she can
speak is Russian so you know if you can
imagine how so they're having their
conversations in front of you okay yeah
I mean I've seen this movie before but
yeah okay so carry on yeah and just as
an aside I do understand Ukrainian and
Russian so anything they're talking
about I know what they're talking about
okay so even her mother was getting on
her but she just didn't seem to care and
even during this time she offered what I
now I retroactively call the ultimate
simp solution she offered to me and no
joke she said if I would continue to
provide for her financially we could all
live together while she continued dating
now I knew this was just her long game
of trying to figure out how can I sort
of stretch the situation until I find
myself a better situation and then you
know screw off how old were the kids at
that point they were
like six and three growing up to seven
and four like they're they're quite
young still at this point
um
okay and I mean like if you got young
kids I mean you're already you're
already in a jam and you're dealing with
a check that's already doing what she
wants and you don't have any authority
over the
behavior that she's pulling yep
um you didn't see this before you got
married she only started pulling this
after I mean you saw no signs this
before you got married
the only sign before we got married is
that she always told me that she wanted
a husband that was just like her father
and her father
well he wasn't a retired uh army colonel
so I think in the Red Army so I figured
he was a pretty uh stand-up person but
when I started reflecting after the fact
what that really meant is that he had a
man that was basically doing everything
uh sleeping separately from like his
wife uh what else was he doing and she
was basically doing everything including
research for her essays typing her
essays doing homework for her picking
her up at the class and she was like the
little princess when we met I guess the
other red flags were she wouldn't clean
she refused to clean she thought it was
beneath her she refused to work
um she thought that those jobs were
beneath her and she didn't know how to
cook which may seem like a small thing
but it's one thing not to know how to
cook you can kind of accept that but
when you kind of refuse to cook and you
expect someone else to do everything for
you then yeah that should have been a
red flag and for whatever reason I was
just too Starry Eyed hey guys I really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out